ich will ihnen liebe zuschauer nicht zu
nahe treten aber ich behaupte letzte
woche donnerstag da haben sie
wahrscheinlich was nicht mitgekriegt da
hat unser bundestag nämlich zu später
stunde und ohne debatte ein nagelneues
gesetz verabschiedet dessen konsequenz
bald haben alle deutschen behörden
zugriff auf die biometrischen daten und
fotos auf unserem elektronischen
personalausweis und zwar nicht jetzt
wenn gefahr im verzug ist oder so
sondern immer datenschutz ist eher ob so
was wie das vergessene thema in
deutschland also ich sag mal so etwas
wie dieses neue gesetz hier
das hätte noch vor wenigen jahren ein
riesentheater gegeben heute geht das
rathaus über die bühne
ihr verstorbener die zeit zweite und
dritte beratung des von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zur förderung des
elektronischen identitätsnachweises
[Musik]
damit ist der gesetzentwurf mit den
stimmen der koalition gegen die stimmen
der opposition angenommen worden
87 sekunden und feierabend ich behaupte
jetzt mal nichts was man in nur 87
sekunden hin rudelt kann gut gewesen
seine sache nicht
man muss solche themen wie
veranschaulichen natürlich müssen in
diesen tagen stichwort manchester immer
abwägen sicherheit gegen freiheitsrechte
ganz ohne diskussion nach 87 sekunden
england hat übrigens die schärfsten
überwachungsgesetze europas man muss
sich also zumindest mal überlegen welche
maßnahmen wirklich helfen und für manche
mitbürger ist datenschutz inzwischen
schon ein regelrechtes fremdwort
datenschutz schütze ich mich die garten
und schon gar nicht die daten anderen
für sich sondern datenschutz schützt die
menschen zu einem missbrauch der daten
hört doch auf das habe ich ja schon
immer gewusst hab mal ja bisher mussten
wir deutschen als bürger den kleinen
chip im persönlichen jetzt seit letzten
donnerstag hat die gruppe und das
einfach mal oben gedreht
das heißt wer ist im prinzip immer frei
geschaltet es sei denn man widerspricht
ausdrücklich dafür muss man auch über
das thema bescheid wissen und nicht nur
polizei und geheimdienste gegen zugriff
wie das ursprünglich mal angekündigt war
auch ordnungsämter das geht bis runter
zu verkehrsdelikten oder so unsere
grundrechte sind leider keine
selbstverständlichkeit die muss man
verteidigen
in der türkei hat man nur wenige monate
gebraucht um die demokratischen
rechtsstaatlichen strukturen einzureißen
und man muss immer vorstellen solche
instrumente müssen eben am ende auch bei
einem innenminister gauland irgendwie
durch tragen
indes der gaul hat sie das klingt ja
selbst wenn sie diese regierung trauen
liebe zuschauer was groß genug ist
wer weiß denn wer hier noch alles ans
ruder kommt in diesem land